continuing in our reading of the traits
of the Prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam
his character
this is again taken
from
for authored
by
zakar may Allah subhah waala have mercy
upon
him
he tells
us in speaking on the traits the
etiquette the character of the Prophet
sallallah alai
wasam he says
that those who are affiliated or related
to him those who are unrelated to him
those who are strong and those who are
weak all have the same
right and all when it comes to their
rights when it comes to treatment when
it comes to they are all equal with the
prophet sallallah alai wasam in the way
that he dealt with
them this is one of the most crucial
traits
that a leader must have it doesn't mean
that every single person is spoken to in
the same way the prophet
sallallah would speak to different
people on their
level if you some
beduin Arab would come to him and speak
to him in a loud voice and the prophet
Sall would speak to him in the same way
and this all goes back
to and so all goes back to the
narration treat people as according
to their status according to their
stature you have to speak to the king
a king and you have to speak to a
peasant a peasant
however
what does not change and does not
fluctuate is a person's
opportunity or a person's rights
with the prophet sallallah alai
wasam in this
sense in this sense everyone is equal
and the same he will not
favor
and have favoritism towards Those whom
he is related to as opposed to those who
he is unrelated to and vice versa he s.
wasam first looks to a person's right
rights and what they are owed and what
they
deserve and based on this a person is
gauged
and never was it
narrated
nor do any of the companions ever recall
that he
ever degraded
any type of food that was given to him
rather if he liked it if it was
something that he liked he would eat it
if not then he would refrain from eating
it but he would never put down and
insult any
food and he would not eat while
laying down on his side or leaning to
one side or another
[Silence]
for
mentions that he would not eat while he
is in a state of leaning on one of his
hands or leaning on his elbows or
something this rather he would eat
sitting up straight and this is out of
humility and in the authentic narration
he States s. wasam I eat as a slave does
eat and I
sit in the position of a slave for
indeed I am merely a slave meaning to
Allah subhanahu wa taala nor would he
eat on tables or on table spread
threads that were considered to be
things of luxury this doesn't mean that
it is Haram it's very important for us
to understand the difference between
what he did and what he
prohibited what he did or didn't do a
lot of that make the most of you know
the extent of it would be an issue of
this is preferred or not preferred this
is more closer to how he to to he ate
or how he sat however there's a
difference between that and saying that
something is Haram because the prophet
Sall did the did something different
that's a different that is a
different subject and often times those
things which he
prohibited he prohibited verbally and
that's why when his actions and his
words when they are in
Conflict we always take what he says
over what he does s. wasam because what
he says is more specific what he does is
more General there could be a lot of
reasons why he did
that
and he would eat whatever is readily
available he was not elaborate in the
preparations of his
meals nor would he refrain from
something that is otherwise permissible
if it is permissible he would indulge in
it Sall wasam but not to access not to
[Silence]
access
as well tells us that the prophet
sallam used to things that were
sweet he used to like
sweets as well as honey so all sweets
and honey in in
particular
the prophet s. wasam was also narrated
to have said as is
in
Muslim he
said vinegar is the best is the best
dip or the best thing to eat bread with
is anything that you eat with bread
obviously there are more this is like
the the most basic level of things that
you would eat with bread something that
is vinegared or cured this is just to to
do away with some of the dryness of the
bread people often would want to eat
meat and these things with bread but the
prophet s. wasam looked at the thing
which is considered the most lowest
standard amongst people and he viewed it
as a
[Silence]
blessing and in another
narration which is also collect did in
both B and Muslim the prophet
s. said The Virtue that holds over the
rest of women is The Virtue that
meat and bread hold over the rest of the
different types of
food
and
his preferred
cut from the different cuts the
different types of meat that are on a
sheep his preferred cut was the shoulder
this is this is the meat and this is the
cut that he preferred the most you know
different people prefer different parts
darker meat or white meat or you know
ribs or what have you he preferred the
[Silence]
shoulder
we have a narration here this
narration is collected by both bukari
and
Muslim and another which is solely in
buari on the authority of
abuur who narrates that the messenger of
Allah s. wasam passed away and he had
never truly eaten his fill
of wheat bread or a grain
bread obviously the different types of
bread the higher more refined types of
bread are going to be white flour
and so forth but the bread that is
usually eaten by those who are
impoverished is going to be bread which
is made of Wheat and
so he Sall rarely ever had a
true full meal with many things to
choose from you know when we sit down to
eat we take these things for granted you
know we have you have to have a main
course and you have to have sides and
you have to have a drink and you have to
have a dessert and this probably never
happened to the prophet s. wasam as a
messenger from the day he re
received until he passed
away it it was a very fortunate time
when a full meal with more than one
thing to eat was allotted to
him
and tells us in and Muslim that a month
or two sometimes backto back would
pass by and not a single fire was
ignited in the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam house and his houses meaning
for his family and himself what's meant
by a fire meaning a cooking fire cooking
fire never being ignited in his houses
meaning they didn't have anything to
cook so a month or two would go by
without eating any prepared food without
eating any cooked food
and tells us that that during these
times they would mainly live on water
and dates this is of course due to
Poverty this is not because this was
what was desired it's not because they
had meat but they chose not to eat it
no in his
book
[Silence]
was
and so it's important for us to
understand the
circumstances under which he was living
s. wasam this doesn't mean that a person
in order to be upon the Sunnah should
not eat meat or should go two months
without eating prepared food only eating
dates and water that's not the Sunnah
that is the circumstances that he
happened to be in with his
companions and for me to have the option
to eat prepared food and choose not to
this is not necessarily the Sunnah when
prepared food was allotted to him he
would eat
it if we had narrations where he was
given meat but he said no I want to be
humble to Allah and I want to eat just
dates okay then we would say that's the
Sunnah but that didn't happen rather
what happened was he didn't have
anything else to eat so he ate what was
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
wasam and he would eat from that which
was gifted to him however that which was
given in charity he would never take
from whether that be food or anything
else and that is because specific to him
and his family
members it was
impermissible for he and his offspring
or his uncles and their offspring to eat
from charity anything that is given in
zakah or charity was made impermissible
upon them
only the rest of everyone would would
eat whatever is available but for him
this is one of the things that were
specific to the prophet Sall wasam and
his
[Silence]
family
likewise in Nei tells us about a very
important trait of his character and
that is that when he would be given a
gift he would always give give a gift
back
now most of the time he would give a
gift more valuable than what he was
given however he would often give
whatever was available he may not have
something of of greater value to give
but he s. wasam when he was when he
would be given a gift he would always
return and reciprocate that gift with
a
gift
[Silence]
well
and in this meaning Allah subhanahu
waala tells us inah that which
translates to and whatever you give of
give in order
to in order to
increase that gift in what you receive
back that is something that will not be
counted and increased with Allah
subhanahu wa taala what does this mean
so often times
people and especially with the prophet
sallallah alai wasam they know that
anytime they give him a gift he will
give them
something that is often times more
valuable than what he received and so
people would give each other gifts not
because they are giving each other gifts
or
charity in order to help one another
they desire reward from Allah rather
they are giving these things so that
they can
receive something greater than what
they've given in that case what a person
gives this is permissible but they will
not be rewarded with Allah subhanahu wa
taala for it rather Allah subhanahu
waala demands that when a person gives
in charity or gives in a gift or what
have you in order to receive from Allah
subhanahu wa taala that it' be purely
for his sake subhanahu
waala
[Silence]
Med
that
[Silence]
and
it's important for us to realize that
this Sunnah of his where he would always
give he would always give back and
reciprocate a person's
gift it's important for us to
understand that anytime he
felt that he was maybe being taken
advantage of
or that someone was going to scoff at
his reciprocation then and he would not
accept the gift this is important for us
to
understand
when you know the prophet sallallahu
alaih wasallam Sunnah is that if he is
given a gift he accepts it
however if he would be given a gift with
strings attached he would not accept
it and so this Sunnah of accepting a
gift from whoever gives it to you is not
is not included in someone who gives a
gift with strings attached someone who
gives a gift with
alternative
motives so for
instance a
judge someone goes to give him a
gift and this person has a case in his
court may he accept that gift outside of
the decision look you know this has no
of course that's how they're going to
dress it up this has nothing to do with
my pending case I just I think you're a
great judge and here's a gift that is
clearly a loaded gift right and it is
impermissible it is Haram for him to
accept
that and for instance if a
person wishes to give you a
gift but they don't accept expect
anything in return
other than they wish to be able to
reproach I gave you this I gave you that
you know you owe me this kind
of big thanks then no this as well as
something that the prophet Sall wasallam
would not
accept
[Silence]
he mentions that one of
his of the narrations that have been
narrated is that he has been narrated to
fix his own
shoes and to patch up his own clothing
is this
always was he was he a seamstress was he
a
tailor was he the guy in the house where
only he would patch up his clothes no
of course not his wives would clean his
clothes they would wash his clothes they
would patch his clothes
however on occasion he would do it
himself and this is this is a testament
to his
humility person of great humility a
person who leads armies
[Silence]
s
so this tells us that he was very humble
this is not an evidence
that you know if a man asks his wife
to to patch his clothes that she should
say no I'm not going to patch your
clothes you patch your own clothes
that's the Sunnah no that's that's a a
different situation right he wasn't a
tailor he wasn't a shoe maker these are
things that he was narrated to have done
on occasion that articulates that what
that he was a man of great humility and
it should not be these things which are
incidental these things which are
narrated they're narrated because
they're uncommon they're not narrated
because they're common if that was the
common
act okay if it was always that he would
always fix his own shoes he would always
fix his own clothes sew his own clothes
patch his own clothes then the narration
would have been in the opposite way it
would have been his wife on an occasion
patched his clothing that's out of the
norm now we're narrating something
that's out of the norm it's important
for us to understand these things as
they are are
narrated also his character was that he
would be very steadfast in visiting the
ill the sick and he
would honor the invitation of whoever
invited him anyone who invited
him whether that person be wealthy or
poor or of low status in society or of
high status in society he would honor
that invitation and he would never
belittle anyone this is
what was
narrated
[Silence]
so just as a
before we continue this issue of
honoring an
invitation Prophet Sall alai wasam
[Silence]
was
before we continue this issue of
honoring anyone who invites him
obviously this is the same thing goes
for this as what we mentioned before
with the issue of accepting anyone who
gives him a gift right as long as this
is something that is there's no strings
attached there's no Al alternative
motive right so for instance we go back
to that example we gave of the
judge one of
the the defendant or the plaintiff in
his court they have a case in front of
this judge and then you know they invite
the judge over to their house for for
dinner or make some this obviously is
something
that has strings
attached likewise we have even an our
time now maybe
somebody you know maybe someone would
invite the Sheik over so he could take a
picture of the Sheik over at his house
and show everybody that hey he comes to
my eyes doesn't come to your house this
is this is something that it's not
per missible but as well the prophet
sallallah alaihi wasallam would avoid
honoring these types of
[Silence]
invitations
tells us that the prophet
s would often
sit raising one or both of his knees to
his chest so he would
sit usually to eat he would place his
left
shank or his left shin on the ground
and he would raise his
right knee to his chest and he would eat
that way he would sit this way often and
this is referred to
as
likewise
[Silence]
for
likewise he would sit cross-legged on
occasions sit this
way in the Masjid and outside of the
Masjid both were
[Silence]
narrated
for
[Silence]
can
he also tells us that the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam would
occasionally sit leaning on one or both
of his
hands you know sitting down put the
hands behind the back and lean back on
them on the floor or on the right hand
there is a narration
in some of the scholars view this
narration to be authentic the majority
of the hu view this narration to be
inauthentic that one of the companions
narrates that he was once sitting in the
Masjid leaning back on his left
hand and so the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam told him this is the position
this is the posture
of Those whom Allah's anger is upon this
narration it is most probably a weak
narration the majority of the scholars
of Islam view it as weak however even
those who view it as authentic the
prohibition is specific to this exact
position which is the left palm flat on
the ground leaning to the left side this
is what this narration is speaking about
but we said it is a weak
narration and in a lot
of a lot of his time and perhaps
arguably
most of the time he would be sitting in
a position of a
is that a person lay sit on his
behind on the ground and that he raise
his knees to his chest and sit that way
and lean backwards this is called most
of the time he would sit in this
position
s
[Silence]
he would
usually eat with three fingers speaking
about about the middle forefinger and
the thumb of the right hand and he would
as well lick these when he was finished
so when he finished eating he would lick
his fingers s. wasam again this is how
he would eat does this mean that it is
pro prohibited to eat with a spoon or a
fork or do use an utensil no there's no
narration where he says do not use
spoons or works it just means that in
that culture at that time this is how
people ate and if a person were to do it
now if a person were to eat using his
hand these three fingers and his
intention is to follow the Sunnah of the
Prophet sallallahu alaih is that theah
the answer is yes n this is something
which a person may do in order to
emulate the prophet s. wasam
further
[Silence]
for
Allah